what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while wall
street's trying to get rich to us that's
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
playing the evilova marinova pump liano
i was ushered out of bed this morning
p-i-m-p we ain't got time
to be sleeping we got work to do let's
go
don't forget the lunch money is now
sponsored by block five go to
blockfy.com can earn up to eight points
this is a fancy hoodie eight point six
percent apy
in their interest bearing accounts go
check out blockfi i'm an investor i love
it they're awesome if you're a user
you're awesome too
blockfi.com lunch money what's up
sleepy i look like i've been sleeping
with this hair
popping out here looking like a tree
growing out inside of my head i was real
sleepy and he woke me up and then i was
like you know
on instagram and stuff and then i i got
up
nobody wants to hear about your
struggles and then i got up and got
ready in three minutes
as you can tell okay ready okay ready
by the way it's 10 30. it's not 10 30.
it's 10 12. let's go i got up at 9 30.
okay reverse so now the people will know
okay the us cdc on monday said it
erroneously posted draft guide
guidance on airborne transmission of the
virus saying the coronavirus spreads
through airborne particles
turns out that is not the case so
it reversed its position and now
dr scott gottlieb says that reversed or
erroneous guidance from the nation's top
health agency on the coronavirus is
deeply concerning and could ruin the
credibility of the agency
does anybody literally is anybody
listening anymore well
remember when masks didn't work they
said masks they don't work
cdc said that it seems to be that the
mask
won't work how did the people know it's
all
nonsense who knows what's real anymore
it sucks
when it comes to the coronavirus that's
literally my position
i don't know i have no clue i have no
opinion my thing is the cdc
literally has one job and that job is to
be
uh issuing correct guidance i cannot
believe well they have more than one job
but yeah
main job okay ready
yeah i just by the way they could be
wrong again
like who knows they may three months
from now they may go and they may
reverse it back
we have no i had to reread that like
three times to understand what was being
reversed because i wasn't
sure you know what it is it's like an
intellectual pretzel that's what the cdc
is they're like a pretzel they just keep
maneuvering through all these things
masks no mask it's airborne it's not
airborne
next they're going to say chrono drive
it a coronavirus drives cars like
literally who knows sorry
um okay you know quibby the streaming
service that i was
wildly not a fan of bearish very bearish
i was the biggest i was a grizzly bear
out here
quibby is now exploring several
strategic
options including a possible sale
according to people familiar with the
situation
from the wall street journal as the
company founded by hollywood mogul
jeffrey katzenberg struggles to sign up
subscribers
in a competitive online video
marketplace can i just say
that the pandemic could have been that
was the best thing to ever happen to
quibby
because it launched in that period where
people were stuck at home they needed
things to watch
and here we are they're not watching the
number one red flag for a company
to not be successful is they raise
enormous amounts of money out of the
gate
without having a product 1.75 billion
dollars
are these people crazy they lit 1.75
billion dollars on fire and most of you
never even heard of them before
never downloaded the app could be
could seek out interest from tech and
media companies
uh and the company's investors include
major media companies such as walt
disney comcast nbc universal it t warner
media etc
other companies quibby may hope to draw
interest from including amazon and
alphabet i don't think they're drawn any
interest
this is this is what we call a dummy
test that's what that's what we're about
to watch here a dummy test
you know what the test is whoever buys
this
is a dummy that's why it's called a
dummy test
right again jeffrey katzenberg is a
legit dude
super successful in one area agreed
but very legit meg whitman super legit
great in one area agreed
when you take people who have
historically been executives at
companies
put them together give them large
amounts of capital and they're not used
to
the cockroach type mentality needed to
build a startup
and to find product market fit this is
what you get
don't die and they're dying they're
violating the number one rule in
startups
which is survive and they're not going
to survive and also
it doesn't help that katzenberg and
whitman apparently butted heads
numerous times you know clashing with
whatever but um here's my question if
they sell it
i mean they're definitely not going to
sell it for more than 1.75 billion
dollars
so i called it a dummy test so whoever
buys it
well what they may do is somebody may
come in and give them
like 1.75 billion in stock
and then that's how the investors don't
lose money right so
katzenberg and meg whitman can kind of
survive and keep the reputation attacked
but this is a disaster and the worst
part is it was so
obvious all along so obvious that this
was going to be a disaster
red flag number two number two
when you have a company that claims to
be a technology company
but it has no technology investors
huge red flag why because the technology
investors
usually passed and they had to go
elsewhere to find the funding yeah it
was like media moguls and big ass
companies there knows connections
remember theranose
politicians invested remember theranose
one of the biggest tech frauds in a long
time not one
major technology venture capital firm
why
they all passed because they did their
due diligence they went and got the
tests
they saw how it worked people said show
me the technology she said no
they passed they said trade secret if
you then
you go and you look at quippy and people
said
show us the data show us the product
market fit he's not saying that quibby
is a fraud
oh no no no no not at all i'm just
saying that
again red flag raised too much money to
wrong investor set
and then three is there it's very
obvious
they don't have product market fit they
don't have the data to back it up
right they have like 90 percent of
people or some data point i saw that
didn't renew after the free trial they
kept talking about millennials that was
the red flag for me they kept talking
about millennials and how millennials
are just
you know that's what they do all day as
they sit uh and
like before they go to class and i'm
like dude millennials are having kids
they're in their 30s i think what you
mean is gen z
but nobody listen to me anyway gen z
ain't buying okay ready
yes tesla shares sank over four percent
tuesday morning after ceo elon
musk sought to manage expectations ahead
of the electric car makers
battery day presentation what is battery
day you may
be asking i do not know you don't know
what is battery day are they making you
have to remember that tesla is not a car
company it's really a battery company
right so they've got the home batteries
they've got electric vehicles
well what they're doing is basically
battery day is where they give an
update on all the battery technology any
innovations announcements oh it's like
well i don't think they call it apple
day but yes yeah uh or f8 for facebook
like it's a day
where they have kind of an unveiling of
all their stuff around batteries
uh and musk basically said
you know look the announcements we make
tomorrow uh it'll affect long-term
production
especially the semi the cyber truck and
roadster but what we're gonna announce
won't actually reach syria's high volume
production until 2022
very shocking to see elon musk try to
temper expectations
but i think that uh there also may be
a little bit of under promise over
delivered today so we'll see what
happens with uh with battery day
um but tesla's a battery company that is
the innovation is they are figuring out
how to make batteries
uh store power for longer which means
then they can go
further for a car a truck etc uh so it's
pretty interesting to kind of see
that they've dedicated an entire day to
the batteries
that's ultimately what's the most
important thing when it comes to that
company um
all right what's next tuesday today is
tuesday oh why are you on page six
because the time 100 list comes out
today and page six
got scoop donald trump william barr
joe biden will be among the honorees of
time 100
the magazine's annual list of the 100
most influential people in the world
also people gotta understand most
influential does not mean
oh we're endorsing we like these people
true uh joe biden
uh kamala harris nancy pelosi drone
power and john roberts
also made the cut what is this political
100 well if you think
if you think about the most uh
influential people in the world and you
say only let's say 10
of them are politicians that's actually
pretty low yeah but
you know who else megan marco and prince
harry
um the full list would be what influence
do they have
he's not even a prince anymore he got
rid of that title
she has the internet the full list will
be unveiled tuesday night
10 p.m on abc and the first time 100
televised
broadcast replacing the usual live gala
yep so i think it's pretty cool that
they're going to do it live on
television yeah that's interesting
yeah when i had keith grossman the
president of time
shout out keith uh on the podcast when
he came on the podcast
uh he said that they were gonna do it on
television
that's pretty cool to do it like live on
ebay is it gonna be like over
zoom how are they gonna no they're gonna
do probably like a live production
tv production but where are the people
gonna be oh the people i don't think are
gonna be there
they're not doing a live gala so they're
gonna do it live like they'll just like
present they'll probably have some
videos play
or whatever yeah but usually at the live
gala people go
but they're not doing that they're not
having yeah i know i know what are the
people participating over zoom or
something
i doubt it who knows hold on hold on
tonight
he doesn't know this yet but we are
watching at 8pm dancing with the stars
with carol
baskin oh you watched it with me last
time no you showed me your stupid little
dance
and that was real stupid nelly nelly's
dope man country grandma
okay um remember that song he made about
give me to par
you don't say pear he said par pear yeah
but he said
park give me to i don't know what this
is
nelly song okay you guys know you guys
know country grammar
please don't ever make that sound around
me again
let's go i'm waiting
not charizard from pokemon let's go come
on come on come on i got things to do
coca-cola will enter the u.s heart
seltzer market in the first half of
2021.
what took so long toppo chico hard
seltzer
will be coca-cola's first alcoholic
beverage in the u.s since it sold off
its wine business in the 1980s
i don't think coca-cola should be doing
this to me i think it's a great idea
it's way too crowded there's too many
players like we're over heart shelter
first time entrepreneurs worry about the
product second time entrepreneurs worry
about distribution
and you know who's got distribution
coca-cola this is a great idea
it's a fantastic idea i bet you that
they are immediately a top three player
in
hard seltzers overnight yeah but come on
there's so many people in the market but
you think that those are just kind of
restrained to the us and maybe coca-cola
can like push it well they just have
distribution all over the world yeah
that's what i mean though yeah
in the us too i know but that's how they
win over the other smaller players
yeah they just have better distribution
that's all that matters in the world if
you have distribution you win
okay you make the rules you have the
distribution
michael jordan and denny hamlin who's
danny hamlin
launched new nascar team with bubba
wallace that's cool
right but who is who is danny
he's a former racer oh okay yeah so
jordan purchased the charter from he was
very good too he won like
40 or 50 races from germain racing that
guarantees a spot in nascar's 40 car
field each week this is awesome he will
be the first black majority owner
of a full-time nascar team since wendell
scott owned and raced his car into
into the early 1970s yeah it's pretty
cool
so look at the end of the day
i love michael jordan getting into
racing you know why michael jordan's a
winner
everything michael jordan does he wins
you know who else loves nascar
aside from like really southern people
eva yeah my dad
he loves nascar for one birthday
we went and he he drove a car around the
atlanta
uh motor speed speedway
it was cool i was there all right but
you didn't get in the car
no way ready for my joke
i guess we're gonna get abused with this
go ahead two drunk guys are about to get
into a brawl
one of the guys grabs a stick and draws
a line in the dirt and says if you cross
this line
i'll hit you in the face that was the
punch line
putting my computer away so he cannot be
looking up jokes
and we are out of time ladies and
gentlemen
thank you for watching today the jokes
aren't even
jokes anymore you're like doing riddles
they're like philosophical they're for
the
intelligent people see he's still
thinking about it because he can't
figure it out
no i'm just i'm listening to my mom in
my head tell me if you have nothing nice
to say don't say anything at all all
right guys that's it for lunch monday
today while wall street's trying to get
rich for us let's just try another one
right
we'll see you tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends